am I really in this yeah like but I mean
it's also distorted hey guys welcome to
a really special ask IG episode I'm
filming this on a Southwest flight to
South by Southwest I'm joined by Jenna
hello
I'm also joined by Adam from the
Southwest social media team and it's
awesome because I've been treating him
and he's here valerio so I'm so excited
and I was like can I dance on the plane
we made it happen
we did it was awesome we made my dreams
come true but this is a nice guy Jace if
we haven't seen the music video it's the
legal description let's get on to the
questions not who are you most excited
to see it's out myself West editor's
note here in the hotel here in Austin
some of you guys might be confused with
South by Southwest is it actually has
nothing to do with the airline it's an
event in Austin Texas there's
interactive there's a gaming portion
there's movies there's film there's
music and it's really crazy how many
people are crammed into Austin Texas so
let's continue is ask I James I'm really
excited about the gaming or its hosting
that was Smosh just to God never been
before
it's a great place to be so all South by
Southwest is pretty cool so fun I'm only
going for interactive but the first year
that I went I fractured my ankle
owl owl gets bruised disgusting
disgusting is what that is it's gross
but when I was dancing all these people
were filming and the woman in front of
me she's I see your channa
look is asking if I'm enjoying my play
oh please
dreams are coming true left and right
left and right forward back lavatory all
of the dreams
[Music]
what is justina Jenna's favorite window
middle or aisle I like the window I like
the second row on the left
walking into the plane on the out
because I always have to go to the
bathroom yeah
same of a window I like the window seat
I like sitting right over the way so we
can see the little winglet and absolute
very pictures that's true that's true
whatever gets get out now this is such a
wide angle fish Lenore so like you guys
are so distorted and like my nose is
just it's like a bubble I can't even see
myself so I'm good
left alone if you fail right now
if I think rebeccablack will go to prom
with you Ryan I'm going to be completely
honest with you and probably not but she
might mean she's like 16 17 18 yeah she
could be on bro when do you graduate
high school that's possible we usually
people ask me to go to prom I convinced
Madison youtuber wants to know why
doesn't jenna is Eric eat meat
I just don't you don't need it that's a
really good answer not like that I don't
have to defend it you know clearly you
did not see my Sassy's ending Matt do
you have any weird eating habits I'm
gluten-free right on of those people oh
you're so beard
yeah just kidding I was like okay we've
got a no meat eater I don't eat me buy
eat seafood at no gluten I try to go
gluten-free but so don't try to go out
to even the three of us so I wondered
about it okay cause you'll be guys I've
never been so embarrassed in my life
no everybody loved it are you kidding
they did but I mean I was like I thought
it was gonna happen
you're meeting with the piggy okay I'm
not gonna like this week like all of my
dreams have come true
I saw the lego movie freaking loved it
then a pig came to my house dream come
true number two good girl good oh yeah I
know he's my Pasha one okay here you go
- number three I just danced on this
plane in you met AR oh my god okay
should we tell them the story so I get
obviously big fans when you're trying to
stalk and figure out who AR was get all
these pictures in our mind we have
several people that tweet so you might
hear from one of my other friends on the
team you might hear from me but if it's
me it says a hawk so we actually met and
I did not connect the dog it's been
years and years ago I was in college a
young little college hey ah no I was
lower case back man
oh I may be recursive yeah yep but we
met at South by Southwest so it's only
fitting that we're going to South by
Southwest right now now what what was
that 2008 I want to say it was 2010
Nicholas is asking everything is
underscore question mark underscore
awesome
[Music]
she didn't see the movie like wait I'm
sorry like I'm confused I think that's
all questions on behalf for today
that was awesome so thanks for chill
with us on this one play thanks for
having me thanks for changing my life
love helping dreams come true because
some fun dance down the aisle at a time
okay guys I'll see you at South by
Southwest unless I post this video after
South by Southwest but I'm already gone
but I hope that I got to see you guys
either way I love you thanks for being
awesome
maybe I'll see you what am I doing with
my hair I'm like
maybe I'll see you guys in the airport
one day because I feel like that's where
I spend most of my time okay